>> PARENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE
BROUGHT THEM HERE.
>> SHAME ON THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, DAN.
AS WE HAVE BEEN EXPLAINING
THE MEDIA HAS PROVEN THEY
WILL STOOP TO NEW LOWS AS
GERALDO WAS JUST DESCRIBING
TO DESTROY AND OF COURSE
DELEGITIMIZE DONALD TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY AND THE STORMY
DANIELS HYSTERIA LATEST
EXAMPLE.
HERE TO WEIGH IN ON ALL OF
THIS THE HOST OF CRTV'S
LEVIN TV, THE HOST OF LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN THE GREAT
ONE I CALL HIM.
NUMBER ONE IN HIS SHOW'S
TIME SPOT.
THANK ME.
LOOK, THIS IS TOO SERIOUS.
I'M WATCHING ANDERSON
COOPER.
WE DID A SIDE BY SIDE.
JERRY SPRINGER, COOPER.
BECAUSE HE ASKS THE SAME
QUESTION AS JERRY SPRINGER
ASKS.
AND THEY HAVE DONE THIS 24/7
FOR WEEKS THE SAME NETWORK
THAT NEVER INTERVIEWED
JUANITA BROADDRICK UNTIL
OCTOBER OF 2016, MARK.
THIS IS NOT TABLOID THIS IS
ZUCKER DRIVEN DRIBBLE
BECAUSE HE HAS AN AGENDA
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
>> WELL, AND THEY ARE
GETTING RATINGS.
YOU SEE WHAT SIXTH MINUTES
DID.
THEY GOT THE GREATEST
RATINGS.
>> Sean: CNN DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE.
>> THE TRUTH IS IF DONALD
TRUMP'S LAST NAME WAS
KENNEDY WE WOULD NOT BE
SEEING A THING OF THIS.
THEY WOULD BE COVERING IT
UP.
HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE.
NUMBER ONE, WHY IS IT
ASSUMED THOUGHT PORNO
ACTRESS AND EXPLAYBOY BUNNY
ARE TELLING THE TRUTH AND
WOULD WHY ARE THE MEDIA
FOCUSED ON THIS?
TAKE A LOOK AT BILL CLINTON.
BILL CLINTON WAS ACCUSED OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
BILL CLINTON WAS ACCUSED OF
HAVING SEX WITH AN INTERN IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
BILL CLINTON WAS ACCUSED AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN AN
OFFICIAL POSITION OF RAPING
JUANITA BROADDRICK.
BILL CLINTON WAS GOVERNOR OF
ARKANSAS, ACCUSED OF USING
HIS POSITION TO TRY AND GET
SEX AND EDGES POSING HIMSELF
TO AN EMPLOYEE PAULA JONES.
DONALD TRUMP ISN'T EVEN
CLOSE.
EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE ALL OF
THIS, HE ISN'T EVEN CLOSE TO
ALL THIS STUFF.
JOHN KENNEDY HAD AN AFFAIR
WITH A MOB BOSS' GIRLFRIEND.
JOHN KENNEDY HAD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH AN EAST
GERMAN SPY.
JOHN KENNEDY HAD SEX WITH AN
INTERN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
POOL.
I MEAN, SO MANY EXAMPLES,
L.B.J. WAS SAID TO BE WORSE
THAN JOHN KENNEDY.
I CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON.
ENOUGH TO OUT MEDIA WILL SAY
WELL, THAT'S A
DIVERSIFICATION.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT'S A
DIVERSION.
THE MEDIA HAVE IGNORED THE
ROGUE ACTIVITY THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE FBI.
THE MEDIA RUSSIAN'S
INFLUENCE IN THE ELECTION.
FBI KNEW ABOUT IT, SUSAN
RICE KNEW ABOUT IT TOLD THE
PEOPLE TO STAND DOWN.
MARK WARNER AND ADAM SCHIFF,
UNBELIEVABLE THEY SAID THE
RUSSIANS WOULD GET INVOLVED
IN OUR ELECTION.
THEY ARE RIGHT.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION KNEW
ABOUT IT, VERTICAL,
HORIZONTALLY, DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES AND DID NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
MOREOVER, WE KNOW THAT LIES
WERE TOLD TO A FEDERAL JUDGE
AT THE FISA COURT TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN AND THEN
FOR A YEAR THEY GOT THREE
EXTENSIONS.
THE MEDIA DO NOT CARE ABOUT
THAT.
SO WHAT DO THE MEDIA CARE
ABOUT?
THE PORNIFICATION OF THE
MEDIA.
LAST MONTH DONALD TRUMP IS
MENTALLY ILL AND DRAGGED OUT
FROM YALE AND PRANCED HER
ONE STATION TO THE OTHER.
BEFORE THAT KOOK WITH BOOK
MICHAEL WOLFF.
NOBODY TRUSTED HIM.
ANYWAY HE WAS GOOD FOR A
WEEK.
THEN WE GET TO HEAR FROM
THIS IDIOT A WEEK.
IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
THE MEDIA OBVIOUSLY HATE
TRUMP.
HERE WHAT HAPPENS THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO.
THEY KNOW TRUMP SUPPORTERS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE
PERSUADED BY ANY OF THIS.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO
IS GET THE PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO DON'T REALLY PAY A LOT
OF ATTENTION.
WHO MAY NOT BE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND KEEP DRIVING
THE STAKE IN, DRIVING THE
STAKE IN.
>> GRABBING ANYTHING THEY
CAN, INCLUDING A PORNO STAR
OHIO NEVER HEARD OF ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE ANYMORE.
NOW THEY ARE PRESENTED TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS TRUTH
TELLERS.
I DIDN'T WATCH THIS.
YOU SHOWED THIS ON YOUR SHOW
EARLIER THE QUESTIONS HE WAS
ASKING.
HAS HE NO SHAME?
IS HE NOT EMBARRASSED?
THE CHILDREN OF THIS COUNTRY
TO LISTEN TO A REPORTER GO
ON AND ON ABOUT THE KIND OF
SEX AND WHEN YOU SEX?
>> Sean: IT'S CREEPY.
>> IT'S SICK.
IT'S SICK.
AND I'M STARTING TO THINK
SOME OF THESE REPORTERS ARE
ENJOYING SITTING AT THEIR
COMPUTERS DOING RESEARCH ON
DANIELS, WHATEVER HER NAME
IS SMOKY DANIELS.
>> Sean: STORMY.
SMOKY, STORMY, NO
DIFFERENCE.
>> I DON'T KNOW, THEY ARE
STARTING TO GET A KICK OUT